good evening i'm pissed morgan
uncensored some breaking news tonight
sad breaking news another unspeakable
mass shooting in the united states at
least six people have been killed and
two dozen others hospitalized in an
attack on a fourth of july july parade
in suburban chicago police say the
gunman is still at large and still
considered armed and dangerous he's
described as a young white man aged
approximately 18 to 20 which sadly
appears to fit the all too familiar
profile now of these mass shooters in
america there are no further details yet
on his moted but police believe he
opened fire from a stall rooftop
witnesses have described hearing a
volley of shots in quick succession and
seeing bloody bodies covered in blankets
well i'm joined now by eyewitness miles
zorenski miles thank you so much for
joining me i'm so sorry you've had to go
through this it must have been an
absolutely horrific experience just if
you could
tell me what you witnessed today
it was gut wrenching
and it was like out of a science fiction
movie but it was so real
um it was a nice day in in our suburb
highland park which my wife and i have
lived since 1976.
i took a walk to the parade as i usually
do for
30 odd years just to
take in the sights
and i was about a half a block to three
quarters of a block
away from the scene of the carnage which
was on central avenue which was the main
thoroughfare of our suburb at and the
cross street was second avenue second
street
and i at first i heard a pop
and then a second pop so i thought it
was a backfire of one of the vehicles
that started off the parade or maybe a
firecracker and then there were multiple
pops
pop pop pop pop
and i'd say there were two sets of pops
probably 13 15
20 each you know maybe 30
overall
and then all of a sudden the crowd
started rushing towards me or going west
on central avenue
and i and they were just it was like
mass hysteria and so uh i was not
knocked down but then i kind of gingerly
walked
forward
and saw something i've never seen in my
entire life even having been in the
service a long decades ago
of blood on the ground
individuals
with blood on them i saw at least a
couple
that had that were in a pool of blood
and not moving as if if they were
deceased
and even i saw i think i saw a young boy
who was ashen in his parents arms as he
was not moving either
it was just horrific
and what makes this
doubly
horrific i guess was that it was on july
4th the day that we celebrate our
country's founding
um and it's it highland park is a lovely
law-abiding community a suburb of
highland park of chicago
we're not a troublemaker or rabble
rouser
and if it can happen in highland park it
can happen in any area within the
country and yes of course it's happened
at churches and synagogues and schools
and entertainment venues
uh it was just horrific tears miles i
it's such a graphic description of what
you've been through and you've really
taken this to
to what happened uh but you hit the no
on the head there there have been so
many mass shootings in america horrific
mass shootings but for this to happen on
july the 4th for somebody to be on a
rooftop of a store deliberately
targeting americans as they celebrate
their independence
it's it's a particularly heinous crime
what does it say to you
coming off the back of so many horror
mass shootings what does it tell you
about the state of your country right
now
well i didn't want to get into politics
but obviously uh um
we need to do more in the united states
elsewhere look what happened in
copenhagen the other day yeah um
to protect us from
gun violence
and those that think they have a free
reign
on guns which they don't the second
amendment in the
in our country is not um is not all
encompassing it's limited
given my my legal background i know a
little about a little bit about that
but
what does it say about the united states
indeed all over the world is that people
don't care about human life and our
politics in the united states
are an example of what is is going on
and
those that don't want to protect us from
guns just don't have the cajones excuse
my word
uh in passing appropriate legislation
but that's a political thing but having
seen it firsthand
god help us all
yeah miles i'm i'm so sorry again to you
and to everybody caught up in there my
sons just got back from being at
university of chicago so i know the city
well and
i use i i was an adjunct lecturer there
at the law school and it's a wonderful
school it's a wonderful city it's been
sadly ravaged by gun violence but as you
rightly say
you know highland is a very nice suburb
of chicago it's not a gang land area or
anything like it and for this to happen
there
on this particular day is an appalling
crime miles thank you so much for
joining me
thank you for having me pierce best
bye-bye wish you all the best
thank you
well i wanted to celebrate over a few
minutes today the fourth of july on
behalf of my american friends obviously
it's a bittersweet day for we brits
because we got kicked out of the country
but america won its independence and
they come together on this day usually
every year to celebrate together
of all political persuasions
but it doesn't feel like that today does
it
this latest mass shooting another
horrific event
in a way horribly exemplifies so much of
the hatred and tribalism
in the us right now it's a country that
i love i love the people
i love the country
but where's the national unity where is
the united states it looks to me more
disunited than ever